escuchábamos el presidente presumir de
las cifras económicas pero desde su
mandato los feminicidios han aumentado
en un 13% él dice que quizás ese 13% se
deba que antes ese delito no se
clasificaba eso es cierto
hola que tal buenas noches muchas
gracias no
eso no es cierto probablemente hubo un
error de comunicación en realidad el
delito está tipificado desde hace varios
años si bien es cierto que hace falta
que haya una homologación en el
tipo del delito no del feminicidio
porque cada uno de los estados tiene su
propia definición al interior de sus
códigos penales y habría que hacer una
homologación del mismo para poder
también dar un correcto seguimiento y
que las sentencias puedan salir de
manera correcta sin embargo no solamente
es eso sino que es importante señalar
que en muchas ocasiones existe
resistencia al interior del poder
judicial para poder
hacer la tipificación de manera adecuada
no hay un maquillaje también de cifras
y eso se tendría que estar analizando
habría que dar una sacudida por completo
para poder determinar qué es lo que está
impidiendo una que las cifras sean menos
negras porque ese 13% yo te apuesto que
es muchísimo más elevado
y 2 también combatir por completo la
corrupción porque el tema de las
sentencias que salen en contra del del
acceso a la justicia de las mujeres no
esto es que los feminicidas salgan
libres o los violadores salgan libres
que tienen que ver también con el
feminicidio
tendría que estarse posicionando como
ahí la lupa no entre entre más personas
con impunidad más casos impunes queden
pues el aumento sigue si el alza no
porque el mensaje es que la vida y los
cuerpos de las mujeres y la dignidad de
las mujeres y de las niñas pues no
importa
hay alguna relación entre este de
repunte de los feminicidios del que
estamos hablando y los meses de
aislamiento que todos hemos vivido y que
han forzado a muchas mujeres a
permanecer más tiempo con sus
maltratadores
sí sí sin duda hay una relación muy
estrecha
justo lo que mencionas que se ha
recrudecido no solamente la convivencia
entre las mujeres y las niñas y sus
maltratadores sino que también pues la
crisis económica que ha llevado o que se
ha profundizado con la pandemia no los
trabajos que se perdieron la economía
que también estuvo como detenida o de
esa valla o empleos perdidos no todo eso
tiene que ver también con la violencia y
cómo se maneja al interior de los
hogares no además de que también hay una
falta de educación en el tema de las
masculinidades no para el ejercicio de
las violencias de los hombres
rápidamente como sugieren ustedes
abordar esta problemática problemática
méxico que vemos que está al alza
pues mira sin duda en primer lugar
tendría que ser no solamente un tema de
educación sino que se tendría que estar
trabajando en las sentencias que se
están emitiendo no hacer una revisión a
todo a todo el el poder judicial
porque por cada
feminicidio que se tiene el que llega a
manos de grupos de feministas porque
están mal atendidos porque no son
llevados con de vido con el debido
proceso
no son atendidos con esta diligencia que
no se han utilizado los protocolos y eso
impacta en el en el final de del
feminicidio hay más hay más violadores y
más feminicidas sueltos y pues eso
permite que crean que pueden seguir
haciéndolo y mencionó si la violencia
sexual porque es un antecedente del
feminicidio